[Music]
well like gravity the russia
investigation is eternal effective
physics in washington it's a constant
force in our lives that apparently will
never go away
we're powerless in its face just because
we're all distracted by Brett Kavanaugh
for a month doesn't mean that Russia is
no longer being investigated and we
shouldn't be very afraid about they
hacked our election
well Fox News can now report that in
2016 Michael Sussman he was a top lawyer
with the DNC and the Hillary Clinton
campaign contacted the FBI and provided
russia-related documents those documents
were turned over just as the bureau was
preparing a surveillance warrant against
Carter page at the moment the Obama
administration was spying on his
political opponents tom Fitton is the
president of judicial watch and he joins
us tonight Tom thank you for coming on
tell us what this means exactly well it
brings the collusion story
look the perkins call a the law law firm
was a cutout originally for the clinton
operation to pay fusion gps and i guess
after a while they said why why pretend
anymore let's just deal directly with
our friends in the obama FBI to target
president Trump and you know it's just
another piece of evidence of the
collusion between the Obama camp and the
Clinton camp and there's no evidence
coming out of collusion between Trump
and Russia all the evidence is that you
were using that we were using the FBI to
launder political garbage as an excuse
to target President Trump and a question
I have always is what is robert muller
doing with this material is he using
this clinton campaign material to target
trump as well well i guess we're gonna
find out i got to kind of wonder about
the FBI and again there's a lot we don't
know and i don't you know i don't attack
people unfairly on the other hand if
you're the FBI and one campaign comes to
you with opposition research about the
other campaign don't you pause and say
wait a second i don't wanna get caught
up in some kind of campaign tactic in
the middle of a presidential year
doesn't that make you nervous if you're
the FBI it ought to look there's no good
reason for the general counsel of the
FBI to
meeting with a top lawyer for the
Democratic National Committee and the
Hillary Clinton campaign the meeting
itself was unusual and the fact that
there was allegedly transfer of
information about Donald Trump in Russia
and we know the information that
generally had been being pushed by this
the the Clinton operation was right
really stuff made up by Russia
intelligence to mess with Donald Trump
so it was fake information used for
partisan purposes and the FBI I was
happy to use it as a pretext as I point
out to target Trump and you got a wonder
Tucker
you know this debate about whether they
classify information and the FBI and DOJ
being very nervous about that for
national security reasons well I suspect
this is why the nervous because this is
the type of information that would come
out as a result of a transparency
initiative by President Trump not just
to clarify nervous about damage to their
own reputation you're saying well and
worse look if you're misusing your
office for political purposes as
government officials in the real world
or the non Washington DC world you'd be
subject to prosecution no that's a word
that's right thank you for reminding us
of that these are crimes some of these
things that are being alleged tom Fitton
as always thanks a lot